NARRATOR: The myth is that,
as the agribusinesses benefit,
the communities benefit.
How's the water at the school?
Do you guys drink the
water at the school?
CHILDREN: No!
It's nasty!
It tastes like blood?
CHILD: It tastes nasty!
Nasty.
It tastes like oxygen.
But in the case
of the Resnicks,
even with their slideshow
ready charity, no.
You see that the Resnicks
jump up the Forbes list
of billionaires, and
the workers can't
even drink their tap water.
And the ironies couldn't be
sharper, because the California
aqueduct literally flows through
town, delivering high quality,
dirt cheap, subsidized
northern California
rainwater to the fields
of Paramount Farming.
But it's not an
aberration in the system.
It's the whole model.
It's not designed or
geared to build communities
and to treat people well.
It's designed and
geared to make money.